a falta de uma visão mais um vídeo e um
estilo ensinar como fazer uma novela
usando uma caneta é triste pois aquilo
que você já deve ter visto vai outro bem
de hoje no canal
agora sei como vocês não têm 43 bem em
casa então eu vou fazer um tempo e
depois de terminar militar escreveu aí
vocês vão encontrar uma página no
facebook e depois vocês vão atender
primeiro à folha por exemplo pois como
ensina popular ump copa e vou conseguir
fazer pelo menos um barco você quiser um
popular amiga que eu fui filmando este
tutorial e foi usada por um quadriculado
para apurar as patas spam que você
estiver em uma idéia de como podem
construir nossas próprias coisas
utilizando papel quadriculado que ajuda
bastante
agora vamos descansar bola com o ombro
pô
acho
ae
o o o papa
é
ó
ele é fofo
o forró
toy story
o som
é
efe
bem
é